foreign
[Applause]
all right
what's up
piece
don't move
female custody we're in the fire
department
stand it up
lean to the right lean to the right
sit up
stand up on
here
yeah there's a fruit buyers
[Music]
come on
yes hey I got a question
what do you got on you what do you have
on here
no more I don't got nothing
oh
okay
you can put your shoes back on okay
here I'll get the other side
[Laughter]
okay listen
right now
okay so I'm gonna verbalize you you're
Miranda before you speak or say anything
tell me okay
yeah the right turn main silent
everything that you say can't be used
against you in the court of law you have
the right to an attorney
you can add a 4-1-1 review point two
free of charge by the courts you choose
exercises right denying statements or
questions do you understand
okay
[Applause]
peace out of here
cover that door cover that door
[Applause]
on the fucking ground on the ground now
right now on your belly on your belly
hands me on your back
who are you
what's your name what's your name
we have it they have her I thought she
ran what they said she was running
which one is she
is that her whoa they have her number
she's like four foot nine
I got it they have her yeah they were
doing that while you were doing this
okay
right
is the female custody
okay so we got him too good
for what
ha why are you running because she was
running
who's chasing who
so you just start running
that's not how it works buddy
what
uh where's your car where's your car
Katie can you bring our car over to the
front so this mail
all right you want to put them in here
any weapons
all right
where's the money don't reach don't read
don't reach for anything dude
you got weed on you I can smell it I
thought we'd um we got it somewhere